hi guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i am going to be reacting to a
video that was highly requested
on my instagram which if you don't
already follow it the link is in my bio
tommy lawrence rant against men
i'm interested to see what she has to
say um
i thought she was anti-feminism so i
kind of
am surprised that this is what she's
talking about but
let's let's see what we got i'm gonna
let you guys trickle in before i
start talking because this is important
so waiting for you guys to get here so
normally i do
final thoughts and i do instagram lives
and i do rants about
politics and there's plenty to talk
about in politics right now
do it every day it's a great time but
something
as of recently has been on my mind she's
very opinionated and i consider myself a
teacher
a helper um someone who could possibly
inspire
people to be better so with that being
said
this is a psa for all the
men out there and all the boys who think
they're men but they're actually boys
this is going to be the summer of
canceling boys now from my own personal
experiences and the experiences of all
of my friends which
range in age from 24 to
36. we've all got issues
now i will also say this all of my
friends are attractive
all of my friends are successful all of
my friends
have something going on almost every
single one of them
have an issue with men and
you have to start looking at that and
thinking
if an age range of that many people
including myself
living really all over the country and
being blonde brunette short hair
long hair i mean tan super white super
i mean these women range in every body
type and every everything
they're all successful they're all
intelligent they're all good people
but if all of these women including
myself are having issues
then i have to think it might not be
us it might be you it might be men
okay when i was younger i had a really
similar realization
like i hated men i swear i had like a
disdain i thought all men cheated i
thought all men were like the worst
and then i realized it was the men that
i chose to date
i was a bit younger than her like she's
like what 27 28 i was like probably 22
when i realized this um
but yes sometimes if you think like an
entire gender is the problem
there's only one common denominator in
these scenarios and it's you
and your friends who are probably
similar to you it might be men
now i've often talked about the
pussification of america
and how men are no longer men i talked
to my mom about this a lot and she says
well maybe it's just the guys in texas
maybe it's just the guys in los
angeles maybe it's just the guys just
the guy
um it is not just the guys in los
angeles nashville dallas
and it's not they're not any better in
the midwest they quite frankly i think
they're trash all over this country and
the age range of about 20 to i think
about
55 maybe even 60. a lot of men are trash
a lot of men don't know how to treat
women a lot of men don't know how to
really
quite frankly pull their heads out of
the sand and pay attention so
i am going to help you and these are
some of the things that i've experienced
these are some of the things my friends
have experienced i again
i'm just going to lay a few things out
they haven't all happened to me some of
them have just happened to my friends
a lot of them have happened to me so the
first thing and i've made notes
by the way i've made that this is how
invested i am in this because i've been
thinking about this for about two weeks
solid now
first question for men if you like a
girl if you're even
somewhat interested in a girl you need
to ask yourself this question
are you single no i don't mean are you
kind of single seeing five people
dating somebody still kind of in a
relationship
you're allowed to see five people if
you're not exclusive with anyone
like a lot of girls do the same thing
kind of broken up kind of on again off
again kind of married
kind of divorced are you actually single
single
that means okay
if they're married or in a relationship
i agree
with this statement but you can't get
mad if someone's dating other people
when you're first when he's first
getting to know you he doesn't know you
single
you have nobody you have no
complications you have no attachments
you are actually single that is the
first question believe it or not that
needs to be asked
and ladies you should be asking it
because in 2020
it's not a given anymore that a guy
that's actively pursuing you is actually
single
so that's it was never a given it's not
2020
it's forever the first thing um the
second thing
that i think is very important that men
don't seem to understand
there are very few women out there and
i'm speaking from personal experience as
well as from
all of my friends and all the women
quite frankly that i talk to
there is not a woman out there that
wants to be
your pen pal she doesn't want to get
your texts
your good morning texts your goodnight
texts your random through the day texts
if they don't follow up with a plan to
actually
here's the kicker in person hang out now
i know what you're saying oh it's
covered people can't hang out in person
this has not been a four month problem
this has been a five-year problem that
i've
experienced with men and my friends
experience with men
women do not want a pen pal we don't
want a texting pal
we quite frankly don't care if you text
us all day or if you don't text us at
all if you're not going to make a plan
to actually see us in person
then he probably doesn't like you i'm
just trying to be honest
what i realized it's a humbling moment
let me tell you
that not every man that gives you
attention actually likes you
like he's probably somewhat interested
but he's probably not that interested
also dating apps kind of hard because
they don't know you at all like of
course they're gonna come on hot and
cold they probably just do it when they
have free time
but yeah if you stop putting an effort
like you should
probably talk to different guys not
interested
and if you do have a woman out there
that just wants to be your pen pal is
probably because she
has a boyfriend or a husband or a wife
or whatever we don't want a pen pal
but that also leads me to my second
point
this is me backwards for you guys make
plans
make a plan i do agree it's very
attractive when a guy comes to you with
a plan
do not assume that you can text somebody
randomly
in the middle of the day what are you
doing or text them at
midnight or 1am or 2am or
even just within hours of when you
actually want to see them
and think that they're going to be
available they might not think you're
going to be available they might just
like
have have had their schedule open up and
just text you like you don't have to get
mad about it
like i mean maybe i'm too like laid back
but if someone texted me that like in
the middle of the day which it takes two
seconds to answer your phone
and said do you want to hang out later
like i wouldn't be mad i almost prefer
it like because i feel like i'm more
likely to do something if it's sooner
rather than days out
for me i personally once i get home
and i take my makeup off and i'm
watching tv
i'm no longer interested so if you
didn't make a plan earlier in the day or
better yet
a day or two or three in advance i'm not
interested i don't want to hang out
anymore because that ship
has sailed make a plan i want to hang
out with you at this time it doesn't
have to even be a date i want to see you
at this time
are you free at this time or when are
you free
i will accommodate my schedule to see
you when are you free
i want to see you i know
it's not rocket science but men of 2020
it seems like it's pretty difficult for
you to figure out
it's not difficult if the guy likes you
just be it odd
like i'm just being honest
i guarantee she's just going for a guy
that doesn't like and i'm not a feminist
so please don't take this as a feminist
and that's not abnormal a lot of girls
do that like
i love men i think men are great i think
men have failed themselves and they
failed us and i'm just trying to help
you out because i think there are a lot
of really great guys out there
who need a little help and i don't think
that there are a lot of women that are
stepping up and saying these things
and not facetiming i swear to god
quite frankly i don't think that there
are a lot of women that aren't raging
feminists
that don't look like lena dunham they're
saying these things to you
so i'm going to go ahead and say them
because i need to be sad i am really so
sick of my friends having to deal with
trash men i'm tired of dealing with
trash men
so i'm going to help you out make plans
so let's go through these lists again
because i know you all love lists
and also if you look at the world
through like the lens of men are trash
like you're only going to find what you
see
so if you think like there are good guys
out there there are guys that will treat
you right
now then you're going to find more guys
that treat you right
you know number one are you single
number two
make a plan nobody wants a pen pal we
want to actually see you
if not don't text us because it's a
waste of our time and we don't want to
see it on our phones
got it all right next thing
value value
okay value value take that in just
repeat it to yourself until it makes
sense
okay if you want to date a girl that has
nothing going on
then that's fine but please do not mix
in
people like me and my friends
one it sounds like the jealousy for me
and two who cares if you're not in a
relationship
like if they want to like even girls
talk to guys that they take more
seriously and less seriously
you never know you could be like his
like favorite
of the girls that he's dating and maybe
he's leaning towards dating you
but like you're gonna get mad when
you're not together that he's talking to
a girl that's like doesn't have much
going on who have something going on
with your other girls that have nothing
going on and by nothing going on i mean
this
i don't there is no job that is
unimportant there is no job that's not
valuable or that's not worthy it is
but if you want to mix in people like me
and people like my friends who are go
getters
who work really hard who make their own
money who are talented
skilled ambitious please don't mix us
in with the thattianas we don't want to
be there
if that's what you want find them please
for the love of god do not mix us in
with them
because we don't want to be there and
quite frankly we take it as an insult
if we find out that you are also talking
to five tatianas who have nothing going
on
people like me and my friends are going
to be insulted by
girls do what if a guy said to you i'm
insulted because you talk to a guy that
works like less hard
than me like wouldn't you be like
like i'd be like it's not your business
who i talk to yeah
and there's almost really no coming back
unless we're dating like obviously but
from it
so if you want that kind of a girl the
kind of girl who's just kind of happy
going through the motions of life not
really super ambitious hasn't really
found herself
yet doesn't really have a whole lot
going on other than she's pretty
please just go after them and please do
not mix us
in we don't want to be there i promise
you
so value value there's a lot there's a
lot of women out there that i know that
are my good friends
who have amazing jobs who work really
hard but
who can't seem to find a decent guy even
if they go up in age
5 to 10 to 15 years because
those guys all want to be with 21 year
old okay
there are so many guys out there like if
you can't
find one maybe like look in the mirror
i don't know and i'm telling you like i
had this realization like
i had the same issue where i felt like
men were trash men were the worst
whatever and then i was like hey
look look inside what do you need like
to change about yourself
who have nothing going on it's very
unfortunate i don't think it's going to
be fulfilling
but i would say to the men out there try
to maybe find a woman that you can talk
to
communicate with might actually have her
[ __ ] together
just because a girl works hard doesn't
mean she knows how to communicate might
actually be
ambitious and have something going on or
want to have something going on
i don't care what she does she doesn't
have to be on tv she doesn't have to be
a phd
she doesn't have to be a television
producer she doesn't have to own her own
company but be ambitious
and have something going on those women
out there
are going to be a lot more fulfilling to
you you're actually going to enjoy your
time
and if you actually might want a
sustainable and healthy
and stable relationship that's probably
the kind of girl you're going to need to
find
not the that's iana's who just want to
look cute
and post instagram stories now [ __ ]
instagram pays
these days i love a good instagram story
y'all know i do i love a good boomerang
i love a good whatever but if that's all
you do
men if that's all she does
probably houston we have a problem just
going to let you in on a little
tip the next thing on my list is this
consistency
it really does not help me or my friends
or any woman in general
if you are really cool and you're really
interested when you first start talking
to them
and then give it three four five days
and all of a sudden you're not
consistent anymore
you don't make plans you don't really
care you kind of fade in and out you're
talking to five other thotiana's
consistency is important now if you want
to be inconsistent and you want a ghost
and you want to fall off the radar
that's fine but i'm going to give you a
pro tip people like me
and people like my friends we aren't
gonna really give a [ __ ] after that we
don't really care
okay i've found that if a guy is doing
this he's just not that interested
maybe he was interested to start now
he's less interested
other thing is like
just
if if you guys met on a dating app it's
not that serious he doesn't know you at
all
so you can't be that mad if he's not
crazy interested the f's have been given
and we're kind of done i'll tell you
this from personal experience once i'm
turned off
i am turned off and i don't care anymore
because there at one point i probably
did care at one point my friends
they probably did care they probably did
like you because you expressed interest
and maybe you were cool maybe you were
kind of fun to hang out with
but if you're not consistent and you
fall off the radar i give you maybe
one to two chances to fix that because
i'm a very direct communicator
women this is important i will
communicate to you if your communication
isn't great
i will let you know that so that more
effort is needed but if you don't heed
that
sometimes like i think that
like one most of the times the guys
that don't communicate well with you
just really don't like you
if a guy likes you he'll communicate
with that warning and i have to warn you
twice
i'm done at that point because i don't
really care anymore now i'm done
now i don't care and i know my friends
who are watching this are thinking and
saying the same thing because we have
these conversations
on an almost daily basis once you turn
us off
we don't care anymore so let that be a
warning to you
you're probably not going to circle back
they always come back
they always come back but when you're
ready to come
when they're horny not for a
relationship back
i probably don't care anymore so if you
want to switch up stay there
pro tip my last and you don't have to
get all mad about it like if that's how
you feel that's totally fine like if a
guy isn't showing interest in you and
you want to cut it off that's totally
fine
you can block his number like you don't
have to get all
riled up for no reason on my list is
also very important
don't be excuse my language don't be a
[ __ ]
don't be a [ __ ] don't be a [ __ ]
if you have then failed and you lost a
woman of value like myself or my friends
and then we don't really care anymore
don't be a [ __ ]
don't be butt hurt you did it to
yourself
okay again block button
so easy protect your energy ladies
protect your energy and it's no longer
my problem
now it's become a personal problem of
yours so don't be
but it's a problem to you because you're
literally ranting about this
and by the way if i'm no longer
interested because
your effort is shitty that's fine that's
not me being a [ __ ]
that's not me being difficult that's me
having a standard
in which i expect from people that's
fine but if you're finding that no guys
meet your standards like
again i've been there look in the mirror
i do have high standards and high
expectations my friends
have high standards and high
expectations do you want to know why
we've worked for those okay we work hard
we're successful we take care of
ourselves we try to look cute
we are have a desire to be something
more each day okay that's why we have
the ability
to be somewhat what you call difficult
it's not
difficult we just have a baseline
standard and if you can't meet that
standard it's fine
that's okay that's fine you just might
not find anyone a lot of men cannot
but if you are one of those men out
there and i i have them all over my dms
sometimes i check them
and you guys are like what would it take
to be with someone like you what would
it take
to be with your friends what are girls
like you what are they looking for
i laid them out for you very simply
there in order to have a shot
with a girl like me or girls like my
friends girls that are
worth a damn you don't really have to be
brad pitt
you don't have to be famous you don't
even really have to make a lot of money
or have a really fantastic job you just
have to
be determined you have to be in some way
successful in that you want to attain
some certain kind of success for
yourself you're driven
you have goals you can handle a woman
with standards that's not going to turn
you off
and you're going to put in the effort to
be with somebody
like myself or my friends we deserve
that
and we will not compromise our standards
i tell you this
it will be a cold day in hell when i
chase a man
and i know that's the same thing for my
friends as well and if my friends are
listening
and they're thinking about chasing a man
please for the love of god
do not because there is not not one
single
man on planet earth
okay that is worth
making any woman feel like she is not
good enough
i don't care how hot a girl is how smart
how successful
how rich we have all dealt with men
who treat us like we are not good enough
no
the problem is we are two enough and you
can't handle it
so those are my checklists
look i'm just being honest
if you're finding that no men meet your
standards
it might be you i don't know i'm not
saying like you're unattractive i'm not
saying you're a bad person
there just might be some stuff you got
to work on and
maybe lower the standards a little bit
in places that like
how do i put it like it doesn't matter
i'd have to do a whole video on this
because like there are some things
like that women like have as like a
standard that really don't make anyone a
good boyfriend so like
height for example doesn't make someone
a good boyfriend
um yeah that's all i got for you guys
today please do not forget to like
comment and subscribe
trying to move out of my parents house
my parents begged me like every day
every single day pretty much
so i will talk to you guys next time